the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today is entitled
differentiation of inverse functions and
pulls together two previous topics that
we've discussed namely inverse functions
themselves and secondly the chain rule
that we've discussed just a short time
ago and perhaps the best way to
introduce the power of differentiation
of inverse functions is to start out
with such a problem let's actually try
to differentiate a particular function
which at least up until now we have not
been able to differentiate the function
happens to be y equals the cube root of
x in other words y equals x to the 1/3
let's find dy/dx if y equals x to the
1/3 now the whole idea of inverse
functions is what that it gives us a
chance to paraphrase that we can
interchange the role of the dependent
and the independent variables and like
any other form of paraphrase even though
two things may be synonymous
psychologically one of the two may be
easier for us to visualize than the
other in particular in this particular
case if y equals x to the 1/3 another
way of writing the same thing is to say
what x equals y cubed ok and now given
that x equals y cubed in other words
with treating X as a function of Y we
certainly know how to differentiate Y
cubed with respect to Y namely we know
that for a positive exponent to
differentiate all we have to do is bring
the exponent down and replace it by one
less in other words right away what we
can say is that the X dy is 3y squared
now if we use the result of last time
that we talked about when we were
discussing the chain rule and I'll
review that result in just a few moments
but for the time being let's assume that
we have the result that DX dy is the
reciprocal of dy/dx in other words if
the Y DX is 1 over DX dy that tells us
that the Y DX is one of
three-wide sweat and I guess to write
that and were convenient form that's one
third Y to the minus two if you use two
exponential notation if we now recall
from above that y is equal to X to the
one-third this can now be written as
one-third X to the one-third to the
minus two and we now arrive as an answer
dy/dx is one-third X to the minus 2/3 by
the way let me point out there certainly
was nothing wrong with leaving our
answer in this particular form
it's just conventional that wherever
possible if the original problem was
given as a function of X we would like
our answer to also be a function of X I
mean here for example we could have said
that the answer is one-third Y to the
minus two where y equals x to the 1/3
all we've done here is to fill this
thing in explicitly by the way there may
have been a tendency and here's an
example of circular reasoning that may
have been a tendency to say didn't we
already learn that the differentiate of
power we just bring the power down and
replace it by one less in other words if
we did that bringing down the one-third
would give us a factor of 1/3 in front
replacing 1/3 by one less 1/3 minus 1 is
minus 2/3 we would then see that dy/dx
should be one-third X to the minus 2/3
which is exactly what we got this way
the point that we should mention that
this particular stage is that the
derivative of X to the N being NX to the
N minus 1 was proven only for the case
that N is an integer either positive or
negative one uses the binomial theorem
to prove the result for a positive
integer one uses the quotient rule to
prove the result for a negative integer
and now even though I didn't do this
thing in general I think you can see how
this will generalize for fractional
exponents one uses the inverse function
idea namely we did have to use the fact
that if y is equal to x to the 1/3 x
equals
y-cubed was an equivalent equation and
we could differentiate that now what
what is the hang-up here insofar as how
certain are we that dy DX and the X dy
are reciprocals you may recall that when
we use the chain rule we showed that if
Y is a differentiable function of X and
if X is a differentiable function of U
then why is the differentiable function
of U and in particular D why do u is dy
DX times DX to U and if we now take the
particular case where the first variable
equals the third where u equals y we get
what dy dy which is 1 equals dy DX times
DX dy and at first glance it might seem
that we've proven rigorously now the
result that DX dy and the Y DX are
reciprocals of each other that is one
the one logical hang-up that we have
right now is simply this in the
statement of the chain rule it did not
say that Y had to be a function of X and
X had to be a function of U it said Y
had to be a differentiable function of X
that was the first variable had to be a
differentiable function of a second and
the second had to be a differentiable
function of the third in other words
coming down to here if we know that Y is
a differentiable function of X and Y has
an inverse function and if we also knew
that the inverse function was
differentiable C in other words the this
must be a differentiable function of
this and this must be a differentiable
function of this in other words the one
point that was missing was is that if we
knew that if a function is
differentiable that its inverse if it
exists is also differentiable the chain
rule would have given us a rigorous
proof the point that we're missing
though is we do not as yet know that the
inverse of a differentiable function is
also a differentiable function now if
you recall on our earlier lecture on
inverse functions
we pointed out that there was a rather
interesting graphical interpretation
between y equals f of X and y equals f
inverse of X in fact as you may recall
by the way whenever I say you may recall
that's just my polite way of saying
perhaps you don't but you'd better look
it up because we had it okay
so recall that the two curves are
symmetric with respect to the line y
equals x by the way again just a brief
aside here notice that either one of
these functions could have been called f
of X and the other one could have been
called f inverse in other words just
another piece of brief knowledge here
that the inverse of the inverse is the
original function again now it was
thinking in terms of our function
machine if you interchange the input and
the output and then of the resulting
machine again interchange the input and
the output you're back to the original
machine again so in this particular
diagram I certainly could have labeled
this curve y equals f of X or G of X
then this curve here would have been y
equals G inverse of X but the important
point is what that y equals f of X and y
equals F inverse of X are symmetric with
respect to the line y equals x now you
see we have a particularly simple
geometric argument as to why the Y an
inverse function should be
differentiable if the original function
is differentiable namely pictorially
what does it mean to say that a function
is differentiable it means that when you
plot its graph the graph is smooth in
other words if F is a differentiable
function the curve y equals f of X will
be a smooth curve now simply ask
yourself the following question if you
take a smooth curve and take its mirror
image with respect to the line y equals
x or for that matter with respect to any
line do you expect the curve to become
unsmooth you see in other words the
mirror image of a smooth curve will
again be smooth and that's perhaps the
most intuitive way of picking off in
your mind why if a function is
differentiable its inverse function will
also be differentiable of course as
we've seen many times
in this course we must distinguish
between geometric intuition and
mathematical analysis that on more
occasions than one what seemed to be
happening geometrically was complicated
by something unforeseen when we try to
get the result in terms of analytic
methods let me give you an illustration
of this you see what we're really saying
is granted that a picture can be a good
visual aid let's suppose we're given the
curve y equals f inverse of X and we
assume that that well first of all what
does that the same as saying it's the
same as saying that x equals f of y at
any rate the question is this we're
assuming that f of that f is a
differentiable function what we would
like to do is to prove that F inverse is
also differentiable now you see the
whole thing again is that whenever you
want to prove anything what do you mean
if you take F inverse and differentiate
it and by the way that may look like a
funny notation think of it think of F
inverse as being one symbol I mean call
it G call it whatever you want all we're
saying is how would we by definition
find the derivative of the inverse
function say at x equals x1 and the
answer is that by definition is just
what it's the limit as Delta X
approaches zero same definition as
before f of x1 plus Delta X minus f of X
1 over Delta X ok and in fact if you
want to write that a little bit more
explicitly what is another way of
writing Delta X Delta X of course is x1
plus Delta X minus x1 now the idea is
this is F inverse C we want to find the
derivative of F inverse who cares what
the name of the function is whatever the
name of the function is what you do you
compute the function at x1 plus Delta X
subtract off its value at x1 and divide
by Delta X so by the same definition
that we had the first time we define
derivative this is the basic definition
for finding the derivative of f inverse
now how do we use the fact that we
already know what F is like remember
we've
mentioned when we talked about inverse
functions before is at the time you use
the way you really effectively handle
inverse functions is when you know
properties of the original function you
see we're not just working blindly with
f inverse here we're working with the
case that f inverse is the inverse of
the function f and that we know that f
is differentiable and now we want to see
if knowing that F is differentiable can
we prove that F inverse is
differentiable and you see the idea is
not really that difficult we can work
this thing out step by step from our
little diagram over here you see notice
that another name for F inverse of X 1
plus Delta X is y 1 plus Delta Y let me
just work with what's in the bracketed
expression over here see the numerator
is y 1 plus Delta Y that's this term now
what's F inverse of X 1 as we come up
over here
remember the curve is y equals F inverse
so F inverse of X 1 is just Y 1 ok now
what's that denominator X 1 plus Delta X
maps into y 1 plus Delta Y well the idea
is this in terms of inverse functions X
1 plus Delta X is just the back map of y
1 plus Delta Y in other words since F
inverse let's write that down
since F inverse of X 1 plus Delta X is
equal to Y 1 plus Delta Y that's another
way of saying that X 1 plus Delta X we
might as well write this because this is
what we're emphasizing see in other
words this becomes what x1 plus Delta X
is just F of y1 plus Delta Y and X 1 X 1
is just F of y1
see again I use the picture as a visual
aid but notice that everything I've
written down here follows analytically
by my basic definitions now I don't want
to overwhelm you with formal proofs here
these are all done in the text and I
think that again for those of you who
are proof oriented the proofs are done
excellently enough so you'll get them
from that and for those of you who are
not proof oriented and next a few
minutes here will not make that much of
a difference but what I want you to see
over here is how this thing starts to
set up now in other words notice that
this starts to look like what let me
just come over here when we have some
more space this is what the limit as
Delta X approaches 0 F Delta Y over F of
y1 plus Delta Y minus F of y1 and you
see if you look at this thing remember F
is a differentiable function of Y would
if this had been a Delta Y approaching 0
this would have just been what see if we
could assume that as Delta X approaches
0 Delta Y approaches 0 this just would
have been what this is the reciprocal of
the derivative of f of Y with respect to
Y in other words this would be what one
would call DX dy evaluated at y equals
y1 remember this this is what F of y1
plus Delta Y minus F of y1 over Delta Y
is Delta Y approaches 0 is that
derivative and we have what the
reciprocal of this thing and in other
words what we will have proven is that
the Y DX evaluated at x equals x1 is the
same as the reciprocal of DX dy
evaluated at y equals y1 the only thing
we have to be sure of in terms of the
formal proof is to make sure that as
Delta X approaches 0 Delta Y approaches
0 and that is not too difficult a thing
to do as I say the proof is done
in the book we could do it here but I
think that that would take away from the
flavor of what we're trying to show you
see the idea is it's fine
to think in terms of intuitive ideas in
fact to level with you as much as I can
of all of my mathematician friends who
are outstanding in various aspects of
mathematics to my knowledge not one of
them works without some sort of mental
picture as to what's going on in other
words you can take something that's very
very abstract and somehow or other you
associate in your mind some kind of a
visual aid that gives you a hint as to
what to do next but once you know what
to do next
you always formulate the thing in terms
of mathematical precision in other words
another way of looking at this let's
give us a broad title let's call this
proof versus intuition and this is a
topic that comes up very very early in
mathematics perhaps the first place
there's extremely noticeable is in the
subject called
plane geometry let me give you a for
instance let's take a typical
traditional plane geometry problem we'll
take an isosceles triangle ABC with a be
equal to AC and what we would like to
prove is that the base angles of this
triangle are equal we'd like to prove
that angle B equals angle C now you
remember how you tackle this problem in
high school geometry you said something
like this well let me draw the angle
bisector here that meets BC at D ad
equals itself by identity these two
angles are equal by definition of angle
bisector therefore triangle abd is
congruent to triangle ACD and
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles are equal and you then prove
that the base angles of an isosceles
triangle were equal now at this stage of
the game if you're anything like me what
you would have done is said this is the
end of the problem let's go on for the
next one but you know if you would pass
this in in this particular way you would
have got a zero and why did you get a
zero well if you remember from plane
geometry there were
a particular format that had to be
followed it was called the statement
reason format and for the statement for
every statement that you wrote down
you'd have to give a reason and the
reason couldn't be things like because
or why not are obvious the reasons have
to be what either definitions or rules
are previously proven theorems in other
words notice that even though we never
emphasized that back in plain geometry
when you were drawing this diagram and
getting the result that was the
geometric intuition part in other words
this was where you showed the result was
plausible the logic part and this is why
geometry is being stressed particularly
in the modern curriculum in terms of
logic notice that once you had your
intuitive picture the statement reason
part followed independently of the
picture you see you used a picture to
set yourself up but that the final proof
hinged on what having the result follow
purely from the axioms themselves from
the assumptions and by the way this is
the basic difference between traditional
and modern geometry in modern geometry
let's go back to the same proof and it's
a rather interesting point and I think
you'll see a connection between what's
happening in geometry and what's
happening in calculus you see remember
how we prove this we said draw the angle
bisector and call this point D and then
we went through this and got this result
in modern geometry they say look at
without looking at the picture how do
you know that D falls between B and C
it's obvious from the picture that it
does but if everything has to follow
inescapably from your rules when you go
through this statement reason part then
unless you have some rule or definition
that tells you that D must fall between
B and C you can't use this result in
other words your result will be
plausible from a picture but not
provable analytically so in modern
geometry we add a few axioms a few rules
of the game
they're called the axioms of betweenness
the axioms of separation how one point
separates other points and what this
thing means analytically
so that we can continue on this way now
you see what I'm driving at is simply
this the utopian way I think of learning
is the first have an intuitive picture
of what's going on then you proceed
gradually to learn what rigor means as I
may have said to you before in the
language of functions rigor is a
function of the rigor e in other words
if a person is perfectly willing to
accept the result and he's not going to
get any trouble using it let him use the
intuitive result on the other hand if
you want to teach him later that there
are pitfalls using his intuition as a
background then we can come ahead and
start to do things in a little bit more
of a sophisticated manner now you see
what I'm driving at I guess is this if a
youngster survives this procedure of
going from the intuitive approach to the
rigorous approach to the logical
difference between analysis and geometry
he'll be in great shape when he gets to
calculus you see the idea is exactly the
same what we're saying in the calculus
is simply this given the derivative of
an inverse function we do it first in a
way that makes good geometric sense to
us then to make sure that the results do
not depend on our picture and that our
results can be generalized to more
variables or the tougher analytic
situations where we can't draw the
picture then we try to pick up the
sophistication that allows us to remove
the picture and proceed purely by
analysis what I'm telling you as you
read the text is if you can do both fine
learn the proofs and the intuition if
you have trouble with the proofs at
least satisfy yourself that they're
there that they do seem to follow from
the basic axioms and other assumptions
but meanwhile rely heavily on the
intuitive results and the important
thing being that you have a picture as
to what's going on the second decided
I'd like to make and in fact I would
like to conclude our lesson for today
with this very important aside is the
following you remember when we were
first learning limits and we talked
about well let me just make an aside
right at the beginning here hate to do
that but just occurred to me remember
when we said let's compute the limit of
f of X as X approaches a and our first
approach was to say okay let's just
replace X by a and you said okay this is
fine but
happens if you get a 0 over 0 form and
the counter-argument to that was well if
F and a had chosen at random how likely
is it that we're going to get a 0 over 0
form that's just what's not too likely
at all and then the answer to that was
but look at every time you take a
derivative you're going to get a 0 over
0 form C and so the question was in
calculus 0 over 0 was very important now
we're going to ask the same kind of a
question about one-to-one functions I
guess the best way to stay is this
bluntly how likely is it that a given
function f is one-to-one for example if
I draw a curve like this is this graph
one-to-one the answer of course is no
for example if I pick the point y 1 over
here and come across here I find at
least in this picture three different
candidates three different X's x1 x2 and
x3 for which what F of x1 equals F of x2
equals F of x3 equals y1 and at first
glance you might be tempted to say oops
we can't apply any of our theory to this
particular function but here's the very
important point very often in calculus
we do not start with y1 and look to see
whether we have x1 x2 or x3
very often in calculus we're standing at
something like all for the sake of
argument x3 and we say hey I wonder
what's going on in a neighborhood of X
string if you want a fancy word to take
care of that it's what the mathematician
calls the difference between local and
global properties and those words are
exactly what they sound like local means
in a neighborhood of a point and global
means let's look at the curve in inner
large you see and the point is this that
very very often in calculus we are not
interested in what's happening globally
for example when you're driving in a car
and you're driving along today the New
York Thruway
and you're near Albany and somebody says
what's our gas situation somehow or
other what your gas situation was when
you were near Buffalo has
no bearing on the problem here how full
the gas tank is and the problems
involved with a full gas tank our local
properties and whether this gets more
abstract or not as irrelevant all we're
saying is that in calculus very often
you're dealing with a neighborhood of a
point and notice this and we'll do this
intuitively the book again supplies the
rigorous proof notice that if F prime of
X 3 here is not 0 but for the sake of
argument in this case we notice that the
curve is always rising notice that with
a smooth curve if it's rising at a
particular point obviously it's going to
be rising in a neighborhood of that
point okay just look at the picture here
and what we're saying is this what does
it mean for a function to be 1 to 1 for
a function to be 1 to 1 on an interval
it's sufficient that either F prime
never be negative or F prime never be
positive in other words what it means is
this that as long as the derivative is
not 0 we can find a neighborhood a local
neighborhood that will make that
function 1 to 1 on that particular
neighborhood you see in other words once
I'm working with this particular
neighborhood and I can't stress this
point enough because it's going to come
up over and over again it's going to
come up with more sophisticated forms
when we deal with functions of several
variables but the idea is what that in a
neighborhood of a point where the
derivative is not 0 the function may be
viewed as being one-to-one you see the
tough part is that if you start with y 1
you have no way of knowing just from
that whether you're new whether you want
the neighborhood near x1 or x2 or x3 but
if you know what neighborhood you want
in a sufficiently small neighborhood the
function always behaves like it's
one-to-one in fact the only problem that
one runs into is the case where at the
point in question the derivative is 0
and I think you can see pictorially what
happens in that case right away as soon
as the derivative is 0 notice that no
matter how small an interval oh I
shouldn't say this is a possibility let
me show you what I mean by that suppose
the curve has a low point here what I'm
saying is if the curve does this then no
matter
small interval we choose surrounding x1
the function will not be one-to-one in
that interval that no matter what
interval you pick here if you look at
the image for every point in the image
there are going to be what two back
mappings two points that come from here
the reason I say you have to be careful
is this you see you can have a case
where the curve does this it comes in
gets tangent to the x-axis and then goes
down like this
you see at this particular point the
derivative at zero is zero
yet the curve is still never falling in
this area this particular curve is
one-to-one
I guess what we're saying here is is
that when a derivative is zero be
careful because something like this can
happen if the derivative is not 0 if the
derivative is not zero then we know that
in the neighborhood of the point in
question as long as the curve is smooth
it represents a one-to-one function and
this is what we'll be doing very very
often in calculus is using neighborhoods
of points at which the derivative is not
zero now what this leads to is this when
you start talking about things like a
derivative being zero and intervals and
one to one this I think you can see that
this suggests a rather powerful means or
need for doing the geometry of curve
plotting this will be the topic of our
next investigation and so until next
time good bye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate